[Music]
Hot Pursuit is directed by Anne Fletcher
and stars Reese Witherspoon and Sofia
Vergara and I believe it's referred to
as a film in some states where I'm from
this is also known as a piece of
the basic plot this movie is at Reese
Witherspoon is an incredibly tough cop
she doesn't take crap from anyone she
goes by the book and she is forced into
a witness protection program with Sofia
Vergara who she has to then transport
they're on the run because she is also
being framed for a crime and so
craziness and I really don't need to say
anything else you guys know what I'm
thinking
this movie was really bad and it's
actually really disappointing because I
am a fan of Reese Witherspoon she's one
of my favorite actresses I've loved her
in movies like walk the line in American
Psycho in mud and even the first Legally
Blonde movie she is a good comedic
actress as well and say what you want to
about Sofia Vergara's voice it might
annoy you but she is an experienced
comedian for television and I was
excited to see if these two actresses
were going to play off one another well
and give us actually a funny movie and
it didn't happen guys I'm gonna try to
be calm and reasonable about this but
it's hard because I just sat in a movie
theater for a merciful 87 minutes trying
to convince myself to not leave I kept
trying to justify the fact that I was at
this theater trying to find something to
keep me from leaving and all I could
think of was these are two very
beautiful actresses they're very
beautiful and nice to look at and
they're both talented in other things
but not this thing so when I'm sitting
there thinking the only reason I want to
continue to watch this movie is because
they're very good to look at that's a
big problem cuz I like movies why did I
have to see this movie why do I do this
and it's core it's buddy comedy elements
just don't work because Reese
Witherspoon's character is a very
uptight loud by-the-book person Sofia
Vergara's character is also a very
uptight and loud person who's not so
much by the book so the only real
difference between them is that one is
more by the book and the other isn't one
has a southern accent and one has a
Colombian accent oh that's good and
funny right that's
writing though it's really not good
writing at all you just have two
actresses who are both trying to play
off a certain stereotype and it got old
after like five minutes in fact it was
never new from beginning it's a comedy
that keeps trying to put its characters
and increasingly more strange slapstick
situations and then of course like
almost every bad comedy ever it tries to
get serious with an actual plot that no
one gives a crap about the plot just
starts to override the comedy even
though the comedy is almost non-existent
I think I maybe smiled once in this
movie not even chuckle this may be like
a slight Harrison Ford half-smile the
Harrison Ford half smile that's what I
did in this movie that's it guys don't
waste your time with Hot Pursuit there
was but one positive thing in this movie
and that is the fact that Reese
Witherspoon and Sofia Vergara have
charisma I'm gonna give Hot Pursuit a
d-minus because both of these performers
do have charisma it's just that this
movie is not the right vehicle for them
something I am excited about though is
that I had the privilege to go on screen
junkies movie fights when I was in LA
the episode just went up today I had an
amazing time with these guys they
actually are real gentleman in real life
which was really cool because I'm a fan
of them it's always cool to meet
somebody and be like you guys are great
and it was so much fun to film this
episode if you've never heard of movie
fights it's a podcast that's filmed in
which people come on and argue and
respectfully debate their ideas for a
movie based question that's asked to
them guys go check this out it's in the
link in the description below I had a
great time doing it and thank you so
much as always for watching guys and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
Oh